تعاهدت المفوضيه الاوروبيه بتقديم بيئه
وخمسين مليون يورو لتونس منها 100 مليون
بهدف في اداره الحدود من اجل مكافحه
للتجار بالبشر بحسب المفوضيه التي التقى
وفد رفيع منها الرئيس قيس سعيد في تونس
يوم الاحد وكان سعيد الذي تعاني بلاده
مصاعب ماليه جديه قد قال في سياق تعليقه
على قضيه الهجره غير النظاميه ان تونس لن
تكون حارسا لبعض الدول
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ونناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه في اي سياق جاءت زياره الوفد
الاوروبيه رفيع المستوى الى تونس وفي اي
اطار قدم الوفد مساعداته الاقتصاديه الى
تونس
وما الدور الذي ينتظره الاوروبيون من تونس
في موضوع مكافحه تدفق اللاجئين وما مدى
استعداد تونس لقبول القيام بهذا الدور وما
هي الافاق المحتمله للتعاون بين السلطات
التونسيه والجانب الاوروبي في ضوء زياره
الاحد ومنعكاسات ذلك على الاوضاع في تونس
وعلى الموقف الاوروبي من تونس
[موسيقى]
في خضم ازمه ماليه حاده تعيشها تونس ادت
الى تخفيض تصنيفها الائتمالي بما يهدد
قدرتها على الالتزام بسداد ديونها وفي ظل
تقارير عن انخفاض احتياطيها من النقد
الاجنبي الى نحو ثلاثه اشهر فقط وفي سياق
ازمتها الاقتصاديه والسياسيه الاشمل
استقبلت تونس الاحد وفدا اوروبيا رفيعا
بقياده رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه الى جانب
رئيس وزراء هولندا ونظيرته الايطاليه التي
زارت تونس للمره الثانيه في اقل من اسبوع
المفوضيه وبعد اجتماع اجتماع مع الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد قالت انها ستقدم دعما
فوريا الى تونس بقيمه 150 مليون يورو منها
100 مليون من اجل مكافحه الاتجار بالبشر
كما اكدت المفوضه الاوروبيه السابعه
استعدادها الاتحاد الاوروبي لتقديم
اعتمادات قدرها 1900 مليون يورو اخرى دعم
للاقتصاد التونسي هذا الى جانب الكشف عن
اتفاقات مع تونس في مجالات عده بينها
التصدي لظاهره الهجره غير النظاميه
الجانب التونسي الذي لم يكشف عن دوره في
هذه الاتفاقات التي تحدثت عنها المفوضه
الاوروبيه الساميه بخصوص مكافحه ظاهره
الهجره غير النظاميه كان قد اعرب على لسان
الرئيس قيس سعيد عن موقف تصعب قراءته في
سياق التصريحات الاوروبيه الاخيره سعيد
وفي زياره لولايه صفاقس حيث يوجد عدد كبير
من المهاجرين قبل ذلك بيوم واحد قال ان
بلاده لن تقبل القيام بدور الحارس لدولهم
في اشاره الى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تونس الدكتور
المهدي مبروك الوزير التونسي الاسبق
واستاذ علمي الاجتماع بالجامعه التونسيه
والباحث في قضايا الهجره غير النظاميه
ومعنا من سوسه قيصر الصياح المحامي
والباحث في القانون ومعنا من روما فرناندو
نيلي فيروتشي رئيس معهد العلاقات الدوليه
والسفير الايطاليه السابق لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي ابدا بك من سوسه استاذ قيصر
الصياح طبعا السياق واضح الذي جاءت فيه
هذه الزياره الاوروبيه
سياق ازمه يعيشها الاوروبيون بسبب الهجره
وازمه يعيشها النظام في تونس بسبب تخفيض
النظام لتخفيض درجه الائتمان التصنيف
الائتماني وبسبب المشاكل التي يواجهها
الاقتصاد التونسي الى اي مدى لعبت هذه
العوامل جميعا دورا في ان تقوم وزير رئيسه
وزراء ايطاليا بالزياره تونس مرتين في
اسبوع وان تاتي رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ومعها رئيس الوزراء الهولندي الى تونس
شكرا شكرا مساء الخير
هي عوامل متداخله ومتلازمه في نفس الوقت
وليست وليده اللحظه باعتبار انه في طرد
تحليل السياسي عندما نلاحظ التقارب
الاوروبي في الشهر الاخير خاصه بعد
التصعيد الذي دام قراب السته وسبعه اشهر
من الاتحاد الاوروبي وعن المفوضيه
الاوروبيه وبلغ الامر الى ان حتى الرئيس
بايدن بعث السيد برانت وبعض السيد السيد
جلباب وجاءت ومساعده وزير الخارجيه
المكلفه بالشرق الاوسط
وسؤال المطروح في هذا السياق ما هي دوافع
هذا التكاتف الدولي الذي لا علاقه له
اطلاقا بموضوع صندوق النقد الدولي باعتبار
ان المليون وتسعه مليار لا يفيح حتى بغرض
خلاص سداد الاجور بشهرين في تونس يعني
المساله اكبر من كل هذا المساله هي مثل
اعاده موقع اعاده استقطاب تونس لازاله
الثليج الذي بدا عليه الامر خلال الاخيرين
او ثلاثه اشهر بينه وبين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكذلك
لخلق نوع من المحرار او المقياس لقياس
درجه تصعيد الصيد قيس سعيد رئيس الجمهوريه
التونسيه باعتبار ان المنحنى الذي اتخذه
في الخطاب السياسي هو منح يعني يقترب
احيانا للخطاب الكلاسيكي اليساري خطاب
التامين وخطاب الندل الند وخطاب القوه
بالقوه وخطاب ان تونس لها سيادتها ولها
كامل السلطات على اراضيها وهي المتحكمه
وصحبه السلطان المطلق على اراضيها سياسيا
وجيولا سياسيا الان عندما ننظر الى موضوع
يجب ان ناخذ الموضوع من زاويتين الزاويه
الاولى ان العلاقات شمال شمال بين اوروبا
وبين روسيا والاتحاد السوفيتي يعني اخذت
منحه خطيره لمستوى الطاقه وهذا
المقاطعه سيدي استاذ قيصر
وكانك تقول وكانك تستبعد موضوع الهجره
وكانه ليس العنوان الرئيس لهذه الزياره
والمساله مساله اصلاح العلاقات الجليد وما
شابه
ازاله الجليده الخضراء الاولى انا اردت ان
اكمل لابين المفصل الحقيقي لكل هذا
السياسي التونسي الاوروبي المخابر السياسي
يتمحور حول امرين اثنين العلاقات شمال
شمال هي فئات في اتعس مراحيلها الان
علاقات جنوب جنوب باعتبار تتذكرون جيدا
علاقات كانت علاقات شراكه خمسه زائد خمسه
بين الدول الاوروبيه وبين دول شمال
افريقيا
وكانت هذه العلاقات في ادنى مستوياتها في
سنتين او ثلاث سنوات الاخيره
الدوله استاذ المهدي
استاذ مهدي مبروك الوزير السابق والمختص
بالقضاء الهجره غير النظاميه هي هذه
الزياره كما يقول ضيفنا من سوسه
قد تكون الهجره عنوانا من عناوينها لكن
ليست الالوان الرئيس وانما العنوان
الرئيسي هو اصلاح العلاقات واذابه الجليد
بعدما فسدت علاقات الشمال شمال كما يقول
ما رايك
لم اعتقد انه السياق العام يمكن ان نعدد
ملامحه وخصائصه ولكن العنوان الاكبر
والابرز في المساحه التي تقوم بها السيده
جورجيا ملوني عرابه التقارب التونسي
الاوروبي
العناوين البارزه واساسا عنوانه كبيره هي
قضيه الهجره غير النظاميه والامر الثاني
ايضا الصعوبات الاقتصاديه وتقريب النظر
بين السلطات التونسيه وصندوق النقد الدولي
فلذكر ببعض الاشياء المهمه في اعتقادي
اهمها ان اول من استعمل مفهوم الانهيار
التونسي وجعلي جرس انذار وربما فساعه تخوف
هي السيده جورجيا ملوني رئيسه رئيس
الحكومه الايطاليه وكان ذلك اشهر فارطه
طبعا هناك وشائج قرب فكريه بين السلطات
التونسيه واساسا بين السيد رئيس الجمهوريه
وجلفهما الاثنان يعني شعبوان يؤمنون
بالنظريه المؤامره
مؤامره الهجره
والامر الثالث طبعا هو الخطاب السياده
يعني ملامح عامه ولكن كما قلت اعتقد ان
العنوان
البارز في هذه الزياره هي كيف يمكن تماما
ان نمنع الانهيار الوشيك الذي كررته اكثر
من مره واعتقد ان اربع زيارات مهمه جدا
قام بها مسؤولون ايطاليون قبل ان تاتي
السيده جورج ملوني تندرج في هذا الاطار
كيف يمكن ان نمنع الانهيار الكبير
الاقتصادي والسياسي العام طبعا الذي لم حت
به وخوفت منه جورج ملوني الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتناسنت في هذا حتى مع السلطات الايطاليه
والامر الثاني ان هذا الانهيار الكبير
اعتقد انه لا وصفه له الوصفه الاقتصاديه
اي اي الحصول على موافقه صندوق النقد
الدولي بشكل مبدئي في صرف كما قلت بعد
تعثر المفاوضات في صرف على الاقل القسط
الاول وهو يعني
تقريبا منذ سنه
ويتكرر يتكرر
الملف ويرحل من اشعار الى الى اخر حينئذ
استطاعت السيده جورج جمالوني بعد زيارات
مسؤوليه واساس الوزير الداخليه ووزير
الخارجيه ان تجس نبض وتستكشف المجال فوجدت
طبعا هناك قبول مبدا للسلطات التونسيه
علما وان السلطات التونسيه استطاعت في وقت
وجيز ان تجعل من الهجره نقطه التفاوض كبرى
ليس مع الاتحاد الاوروبي فقط ولكن ايضا مع
صندوق النقد الدولي وهنا تكمل البرمتيه
التي تحلت بها الدبلوماسيه التونسيه في
الاسابيع القليله الفارطه نمضي الان بحزمه
وعود رغم انه وسنعود اعتقد فيما سبق رغم
انه التسريبات شحيحه ولكن يمكن ان نقول ان
هناك تم اذابه الجليد اول مع السلطات
الاتحاد الاوروبي واعتقد انه
الصديق قيصر لما الى هذا بعد ان كان جوزيف
بوريل يعني في تصريحات متشنده مع
السلطات التونسيه يبدو الان ان نذهب اكثر
فاكثر الى كما قلت تدوير الزوايا وايجاد
قاعده التفاوض مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
مقدمه لتفاوض اكمل مع صندوق النقد الدولي
وهنا السؤال الثاني والمهم في هذه الحلقه
وتوجه به ضيفنا من من روما السيد فيرناند
فرناندو انالي فيروتشي
في مقابل ماذا ما هو الدور الذي يريد
الاوروبيون بعد اعاده اكتشافهم
للنظام في تونس بعد فتره من البرود
والجفاء بين القاده الاوروبيين والرئيس
قيس السعيد ما الدوري المطلوب منه
اولا دعوني اقول ان ايطاليا وبقيه البلدان
الاوروبيه تزداد قلقا بسبب الاوضاع في
تونسيا وبالطبع
الامر الامر له علاقه
بالهجره غير الشرعيه
صوت الضيف ينقطع من المصدر
ويبدو ان الامر يهدد استقرار البلد وتونس
شريك مهم لتونس لايطاليا وتونس عفوا شريك
لاوروبا ولا ايطاليا تحديدا نعم صحيح انه
في اوروبا وفي ايطاليا لدينا بواعد قلق
ازاء بعض القرارات التي اتخذها الرئيس قيس
سعيد والاجراءات التي قام بها والتي لا
تتماشى مع معاييرنا للديمقراطيه
لكن اعتقد ان المشكله سيتم حلها لان هناك
رغبه متبادله
ينقطع من المصدر هناك محاوله لاخراج تونس
من المازق الذي هي فيه وايضا محاولات لحل
الموقف مع صندوق النقد الدولي والمساعدات
الماليه التي وعدها وعدتها
المفوضيه الاوروبيه بمبلغ 900 مليون يورو
[موسيقى]
المساعده الماليه الاوروبيه
لتونس مهمه ويمكن ان تمهد
لدور لصندوق النقل الدولي وبعد لقاءات
الاحد نامل ان تتم مفاوضات مع صندوق النقد
الدولي وتنتهي الى النجاح والوضع سيستقر
في تونس
وسيجعل من تونس في موقف افضل للسيطره على
الهجره غير الشرعيه غير النظاميه
بغض النظر عن مدى عن حجم قرض صندوق النقد
الدولي يعود الى الاستاذ قيصر الصياح فانه
يفتح
يفتح ابواب ائتمانيه كبيره لتونس هي
ومؤسسه ماليه عالميه كلمه صندوق النقد
الدولي تحديدا تحدثت عنها جورج رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه وقالت انها ستساعد ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيساعد ارسنال بندرلاين
قالت ان 900 مليون يورو مرهونه
بالوصول لاتفاق مع الجانب التونسي فيما
يتعلق بقضيه الهجره غير النظاميه برايك ما
هي ملامح هذا الاتفاق ما المطلوب من تونس
تحديدا استاذ قيصر
هو بقطع النظر عن كل هذا انا عندما قلت في
الاول امرين متلازمين
فالامر الرئيسي والمحوري وهو ازاله الجليد
بين اوروبا وبين تونس لما يعني به من تعكر
ومن حاله تصعيد طيله تقريب سنه ونصف
وسنتين وهذا كان امرا تقريبا يدعو الى
القلق وهو امر يجعل التقارب مع صندوق
النقد الدولي تقريبا شبه مستحيل باعتبار
انه الامر لا يتعلق
لتدخل
الدولي كان فرنسا كان بامكان المانيا كان
بامكان الولايات المتحده شريك مميز كل
هؤلاء لم تتدخلوا ثلاث سنوات الامر ليس
هذا الامر وازاله يعني الجليد بين اوروبا
وتونس وهو مدعاه السيد جميلوني الى الرجوع
استاذ قيصر فيما يتعلق بالمطلوب من تونس
ما هو ما هو المطلوب من تونس
المطلوب من تونس في الجزء الثاني بعد ان
تحدثت عن محور المحور الاول المطلوب من
تونس هو كبح جماع الهجره الجماعيه غير
النظاميه
تحت وذلك
في تونس بمقابل وهو الامر الذي رفضه رئيس
الجمهوريه التونسيه مجعل تونس بمثابه
الحارس
اصبحت كل الطرق تؤدي الى تونس وليس كل طرق
وهو خطاب السياسي مبطن ومنمق وواضح جدا
جدا لمن يدرس العبارات ومصطلحات السياسيه
في العمق وكذلك الامر الثاني وهو المهم
ذبح الجماع عبر الحدود بضخ اموال ليست
بالكثير قليله جدا 150 مليون اورو تقريبا
نفس المبلغ الذي دفع المغرب منذ اربعه
وخمس سنوات يعني مثلا ليس اموال المساله
هي تقارب هي ازاله الجليد وكذلك تحقيق لكن
في موضوع الهجره في موضوع الهجره يعني
هنالك نماذج انت ذكرت ذكرت المغرب هنالك
نموذج اخر هو نموذج رواندا هل يمكن ان
تصبح تونس رواندا شمال افريقيا
لا لا مستحيل الامر مستحيل هي تونس الان
يعني كما قلت الامر اعطي الى المغرب ونجحت
نسبيا فيما يتعلق بالهجره عبر مضيق جبل
طارق الى اسبانيا ولكن هذا ليس بالامر
الكافي وال 150 مليون اورو او 700 مليون
يورو بالحجم الثقيل لانعاش اقتصاد كامل
يتهاوى تقريبا في اتعى درجاته الان اردت
فقط ان اعرج على نقطه مهمه واهمه جدا
زياره رئيس الوزراء الهولندي وسيده
ميلوني تعكس اهميه كبيره في مكون كنت
اقوله الان في الامر المتلازم الاول
والثاني باعتبار انه هولندا ويتالي
وبلجيكا هم انساهموا في نقله المجموعه
الاوروبيه
وجعله
الاوروبيا يعني اهم ركائز في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
في الخليج ولا في دول افريقيا احدث مثل
هذه الزياره بهذا الحجم
يعني هنالك في تونس من يرى الامر على غير
هذا النحو تماما بل يرى ان هذه الزياره
لها اهداف اخرى المنتدى التونسي على سبيل
المثال للحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
انتقد اهداف الزياره الوفد الاوروبي
الرفيع لتونس بشان ملف الهجره قال في بيان
ان زياره الوفد الاوروبي تخفي ابتزازا
يقوم على مقايره المساعدات الاقتصاديه
بلاعب دوري شرطي الحدود وفق البيان وساده
المهدي المبروك هذا البيان هو عكس ما
يقوله الرئيس قيس سعيد رئيس قيس سعيد يقول
انه لن يقبل بان تكون تونس حارسا
لدولهم يقصد دول الاتحاد الاوروبي هنالك
من يرى غير ذلك ان بالفعل كل هذه
المستعدات لن تكون الا للقيام بدور الحارس
نعم اعتقد انه اولا تونس منذ سنه
2003 حينما نقحت القانون 3 فيفري 2004
كان هذا عنوان بارز لما نسميه بذل العنايه
او المساهمه في مكافحه الهجره غير الشرعيه
او غير النظام احنا اذا تونس منذ سنوات
حتى منذ يعني
سلطه الرئيس
السابق بن علي حينئذ انخرطت في هذا في هذا
الجون ولكن اعتقد في السنوات الاخيره ربما
ربما وجدت تونس اولا عاجز تماما نظرا
للصعوبات الاقتصاديه والماليه عن مكافحه
الهجره غير الشرعيه بين ظفرين اضع ودائما
هذه الكلمات حسب سلطات التونسيه لاسباب
عندها واسباب اللوجستيه اي عجز الماليه
العموميه عن توفير الامكانيات اللازمه
سواء كانت يعني بواخر او سكنت يعني اكبر
سواحل الى الى غير ذلك تدريب تدريب القوات
الامنيه البحريه يعني
الاستعلام تبادل المعطيات كل هذه المسائل
اللوجستيه تونس عاجزه عنها تماما لاسباب
ماديه ولذلك ولذلك تامل تونس تماما ان
تتوفر لها الامكانيات الماديه عنك من خلال
التعاون مع الاتحاد الاوروبي من اجل تحديد
الاسطول لمكافحه الهجره غير شرعيه اما
الامر الثاني لا توجد وصفه سحريه بعض
ظاهره الهجره وهي تقريبا
قواعد مثل للتعاون التونسي الايثالي من
خلال مشاريع او من خلال مثلا ولكن لم تبين
السلطات الايطاليه اي بائخه امل في ان
يمكن يعني الاستثمار
الاستثمار الاقتصادي العميق والمتطور وعلى
المدى الطويل من اجل كما قلت تخفيف حده
الهجره واساس الهجره التونسيين الى
الدولار وبالتالي انا في اعتقادي ان الامر
يذهب تماما
في اتجاه امرين اولا كما قلت تجديد
الرقابه ولذلك اعطت تونس فقط مثالا حتى
تحفز السلطات الايطاليه والسلطات
الاوروبيه على الذهاب قدما مثلا بينت انه
حينما ابدت السلطات حسبها الكافي خلال شهر
ماي
انخفضت اعداد المهاجرين بشكل حاد تجاه
السلطات تجاه عفوا الشواطئ او الحدود
البحري وبالتالي
[موسيقى]
انا اتفق مع التعليقات التي ادلى بها
المتحدث السابق وفي واقع الحال حتى نهايه
ابريل راينا زياده كبيره في عدد المهاجرين
الذين كانوا يصلون الى السواحل الايطاليه
قادمين من تونس كبلد عريقه عبور
في روتشي فيما يتعلق بالثمن السياسي
والحقوقي الذي تحدثت عنه منظمات حقوق
الانسان والذي كان عاقبه في سبيل التقارب
التونسي الاوروبي من قبل هل انتهى كل ذلك
الان لم يعد موجودا
الى حد ما ما تزال هذه
القرارات
كعراقيل ولهذا السبب تواجه تونس هذه
الصعوبات في مفاوضاتها مع صندوق النقد
الدولي لهذا السبب بسبب ما ظهر من صعوبات
مع صندوق النقد الدولي وفي العلاقات مع
الاوروبيين وغيرهم هناك محاوله لحلها طبعا
نحن نريد سويه ان نسيطر على تدفق
المهاجرين هذا من مصلحتنا لان تونس قريبه
منا جغرافيه وهي مهمه ايضا لتدعيم استقرار
تونس بحد ذاتها نشكرك شكرا جزيلا
معهد العلاقات الدوليه والسفير الايطالي
السابق لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي روما ونشكر
ضيفنا من سوسه قيصر الصياح المحامي
والباحث في القانون وضيفنا من تونس
الدكتور المهدي مبروك الوزير التونسي
الاسبق واستدعي من الاجتماع بالجامعه
التونسيه والباحث في قضايا الهجره غير
النظاميه
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
دمتم في رعايه
[موسيقى]